alcatra with a 2-3 record a 363 era he
was dominating in a performance against
the phillies last week at citizens bank
park here's brad miller
miller playing in left field tonight
batting at 329 he's on a hot streak
right now he's got
multiple hit games in three straight
well for brad miller he's probably the
only guy in this phillies lineup that
has had very good success against sandy
he's four for five with a home run
hitting 800.
here's the one and two pitch and miller
grounds the ball to the right side up
with a jazz with a spectacular play
throws to first for the out
jazz chisholm diving to his right
smothering the ball rolling over top of
the ball did a 360 popped up to a knee
and fired to first for the out four to
three
one two three the fills are gone marlins
coming up next and then vince velasquez
is on the mound to pitch tonight's game
for the phillies feel bad of course in
the ninth spot
how to bring up miguel rojas who has
done a whole lot of damage against the
phillies
last few years
and miguel rojas standing in he's
hitting 282.
the o2 pitch on the way swing it up miss
he got him with a fastball
rojas tipped it foul right into the mitt
of andrew knapp and there's the first
strikeout in the first out of the game
for vince
that brings up jesus aguilar who starts
the day tied for the national league
lead and runs bad again 1-0 from
velasquez
to aguilar jazz goes pitch low here
comes the throw
fobbled by segura another stolen base
for jazz chisholm
velasquez two looks back to second now a
third look and he's coming home with the
pitch swung on and popped up this one's
on the infield a mile high up there and
now segura and hoskins nearly collide in
fact they do but segura keeps his feet
and makes the catch as hoskins got out
of there
right behind the pitcher's mound and
there's the second out
adam duvall is the batter
the ball only had the one hit last night
the home run
runner goes the throw to third and he is
out at third base
he wants him to look but that's just not
smart you got one of the top rbi guys in
the league you're going to get thrown
out at third
duvall is up he was up when chisholm was
thrown out one-two pitch on the way
breaking ball strike three called got
him with a curve
and there's the second strikeout for
vince velazquez
vince who
a couple of starts ago said this is the
best
stretch of consecutive starts three
consecutive starts he's probably ever
had
brings up the pitcher
sandy alcatra who is two for 19 at the
plate this season one two pitch and he
offered at it again and missed it strike
three
that'll go down as the third k for vince
velazquez
as the bases are loaded here for jesus
aguilar popped out
on the infield his first time up and as
we said 35 runs batted in that's the
most in the national league tied for the
most anyway
and a line drive out toward left and
right at brad miller hit it right on the
nose
and the side is retired
velasquez works himself in and out of
trouble here in the third
reese hoskins coming up phil's and
marlins scoreless fourth inning
miller leading off from first again
and not going this time of the pitch
swung on and hit high and deep left
field and forget about it it is gone
and rhys hoskins
hits a bullet out to left
it's his 10th home run of the season and
the phillies are on the board they lead
it two to nothing so the phillies strike
first tonight here's alec balm the pitch
is over strike three called
on bowm
so
home gets called out on strikes to end
the inning but the damage has been done
a two-run homer by reece hoskins alfaro
granted to short his first time up the
one-two pitch check swing
the ball was in the dirt they appeal he
went around and knapp picks it out
throws to first to complete the
strikeout
so alcantara
2-2
swing and a miss he struck him out
five k's now for vince velasquez and
five shutout innings tonight
against miami we're going to the sixth
it's the phillies two in the marlins
six in a row have been retired by
alcantara as he faces gene segura here
well there's a strikeout right there
there's jesus aguilar
one-two pitch to him
on the hands rolled over to third right
on the knuckles and bone throws out
aguilar six scoreless hittings
outstanding work by vince velasquez
vince was shushing the crowd as he was
walking off
miller today is
oh for two reached on a fielder's choice
in the fourth inning with two outs he
was on
for the hoskins at bat and hoskins hit a
two run homer
the pitch swing and a miss sandy uh
with the changeup struck out brad miller
one down here in the seventh inning
first time up hoskins ground it out and
then you know what he did the next time
in the fourth
that time he went around sandy now with
four strikeouts three in a row going
back to the sixth
is john bertie getting ready to come to
the plate
here's the 2-0
and a swinging a ground ball back
through the middle might have been
deflected by coonrod out to second
segura's got it
fires it to first in time to get john
birdie and that'll do it
for the marlins no runs on one hit two
men were left were through seven in
miami
philly's up two now
he's on over two but two great at bats
flew out to the track and left and then
a bullet right at dickerson last time up
too top of the eighth inning with two
outs 92 pitches is still throwing 97.98
miles an hour tapper first base side
sandy picks it up underhands to aguilar
for the out that goes one to three
nice work sandy alcatra through eight
innings
however the phillies lead
here's jazz chisholm
2-2 swinging a miss strike three
that's it for jazz again
uh sinker at 99.
watch jazz walk off what's going on
and corey dickerson's coming up
and he pops it up out to center field
oh double says he has it he's under it
makes the catch and the ball game is
over and the phillies hang on and win it
by a final score of two nothing